un couronnement et une vie chamboulée
depuis un mois le quotidien dambre bauza
a changé des journées charge et rythmée
par des cours d'élocution de culture
générale ou comme ici de maquillage avec
un pinceau tu va dégrader pour que ça
fasse naturel par le contour à l'été
j'étais habitué à regarder quelques
tutos sur internet afin de connaître
quelques buzz et avec armelle j'ai
appris vraiment à connaître mon visage
ce qui va avec moi ce qui ne va pas par
rapport au temps et c'est vrai que c'est
très différent des tutos on est là
vraiment pour leur apprendre à se
découvrir
des fois elle est partie de zéro et
après elle s'est débrouillée vraiment
comme des championnes une mise en beauté
mais aussi des essayages sous le regard
et les conseils de christelle marcos
cette jeune styliste a remporté l'appel
d'offres du comité miss france pour
réaliser le costume régional que portera
en bauza lors de l'élection miss france
en décembre prochain
je me suis inspiré de du costume
traditionnel la menthe adam que j'ai
revisité avec des codes et tendances
stylistiques
donc voilà de modernité à quelques jours
du départ l'heure est aux préparatifs
pour la lucéenne de 21 ans deux valises
de robes chaussures et accessoires une
garde-robe pour le jour j mais aussi
pour le voyage d'intégration à tahiti en
compagnie des autres nice c'est surtout
le ministre s de ne rien oublier qu'on à
chaque voyage sauf que leïla encore
décuplée par ce que c'est vraiment le
voyage de miss france de la préparation
à tahiti est vraiment chaque détail
compte
donc quand les gens s'approchent comme
sa petite pression effectivement parce
que on entre on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps à faire les choses il faut les
faire bien de façon que l'ami soit pas
embêtés arrivés sur place qui lui
manquait à rien du tout le 14 décembre
prochain
ambre représentera la martinique à
l'élection miss france
la grande soirée du couronnement est
prévu à marseille